Chris kappa's family and friends had
waited weeks for this
a moment to more
in the front row his parents facing not
just the reality of a burial but the
prospect of life without him
his cousin voicing their pain
his body is a representation
because Chris isn't here but we're still
here we can keep fighting for him
foreign
brothers and cousins
you know the uncles
he wasn't just a son but a father who
never got to meet his daughter she was
born this week his fiance's family here
to pay him tribute to Chris I know you
wouldn't be
busy or maybe this but I love you so
much that I'm going to tell your baby of
how good on my dad and we're going to
it's been nearly three months since his
death and today Chris Cabell was laid to
rest it was a public event with hundreds
of people here but it also felt deeply
private with testimonies from his
friends and his family
now the focus switches to the
independent office for police conducts
investigation into his death
it says that will take six to nine
months and it understands that people
want answers quickly but this is a
complex process involving a significant
amount of evidence
his loved ones have now shared their
sadness and said goodbye but until the
legal processes are complete they won't
yet have closure
Sky News South London